welcome to spoiler corner I think you
got a lot to talk about
spider-man fam oh my god when Stacey
dies which is not a surprise at all I
think they practically have been
building it up in the trailer you know
like she's falling it close by as I
don't need the basic spider-man's like
yeah wonder what's gonna only reason
it's a surprise is because we were
three-quarters of the way through the
movie and I'm like holy shit are they
still gonna fit that in somehow like
there's so much crap going on in this
movie um but you know about how she
originally died it was supposed to be
replaced Mary Jane in the Raimi Phil I
mean the the means in which she died I
mean obviously in the comic it was on
the bridge in this one that's in a clock
tower I don't give crap out that the
location honestly I thought the location
was kind of cool oh yeah and as a
replacement for the bridge it um my
biggest issue is when you read the
comics
um because I grew up with spider-man um
obviously the issue in question came out
during the Nixon administration so I
didn't read it firsthand but as a
spider-man fan I bought you know well
you can see something stuff back here
but I bought all these whoo and got one
of them right here yeah so like I bought
all of these things and these sort of
collections and stuff on me this is the
column or whatever um you know and I
started reading them and you know as a
kid this is back before Wikipedia and
stuff you just didn't know about these
things offhand so if you just started
reading this you know from the beginning
and back issues and stuff you know you
had no idea was gonna happen so I read
one of these collections or whatever and
got to that issue um that's completely
traumatized
because it's like the only way to
compare it is like killing Janet Leigh
and psycho Oh spoilers for psycho I
guess but it's like that shower scene
it's like when that was released you
just didn't see it coming like well no
you can't do that that she's a major
character I'm like holy shit so it was
just such a pivotal moment in in really
comic book history um so when the ringi
films came
and they did be seen with the Green
Goblin and mary-jane I like rolled my
eyes and I almost want to get up and
walk out of the theater because I was
like in the movie for the most part up
till then I'm like I was pretty solid
when it got to that climax I was like
bullshit because you know they're not
going to kill Mary Jane on topic Gary's
ever every age every way you cannot
recreate they never recreate that yeah
so I just thought this is a cheap
cop-out if it was Rhaenys idea or David
Koepp Sai dia or Sony's idea I don't
care whose idea was you should be
horsewhipped because it was terrible um
so that pissed me off and since then
going through three films when they
brought Gwen Stacy into three like I
rolled my eyes again so I'm like well
you already played your card by
referencing Nancy in the first movie no
you're not going to kill Gwen Stacy but
then what they did with Gwen Stacy's
character in three was such bullshit
anyway so I just have dwelled I'm done
I'm never going to see this frickin
scene the one of the greatest scenes in
comic book history because what the fuck
moments um then this one comes around
what made this scene so in like really
emotional and really epic in the comics
was the fact that spider-man had a
history with the Green Goblin with
Norman Osborn not Harry so there is this
connection between the two I mean these
sort of arch rivals who constantly are
going at it and these you know nearly
killed Peter a number of times and like
this is your guy this is your main
spider-man villain and finally he does
this and it's like the final straw it is
the ultimate like oh my god this is the
worst thing you could do the Peter
Parker outside of either killing at May
or killing Parker himself um and because
of that connection they had for so long
you were so invested in like oh my god
this is it I can't believe he way he
finally went too far he finally went
that far and you know and I know there's
something well anyway it was a choice
for the hero to because he still get
save the kids yeah
or the people in the car whatever that
was or but something like that wasn't
indeed still let them both go was an
antic this guy was oh no was it just one
oh no I think the the Goblin drops gwen
stacy
spiderman flings that bernie i mean this
is i okay think about this how fucked up
this is spiderman throws no it doesn't
break he throws his web grabs her but
the rarely the physics of it cuz he's a
superhero he can take these sort of
things but literally the whiplash effect
like snaps her neck
oh is that okay yeah and the witch thing
kind of doing this and i'm away me
she'll be like his web she kinda hits
the ground maybe ya know it has is it
was very effectively cleverly done cuz
it was like so close and it yeah just
it's only so much like you've gotta win
the goblin is so just brushed dick well
known that i don't see is such a dick he
even tells spider-man this is like hawk
you think I killed her you did it you
and your stupid web snap dyrdek she was
dead before even hit the ground like you
know so maybe the baby it did break I
gotta read this comic again I mean it's
been well more than ten years since I've
taken a look at it so I'm sure people
and hobbits will let us know yeah I'll
let us know so but but I mean that the
point is of the scene and like don't go
nuts correcting me but is the cruelty of
it that spider-man played a part in the
bill red death and the build-up in the
fact that it's such a connection so
here's my problem with the movie Harry
just shows up at the beginning of the
film we haven't seen any part of him and
it's like oh hey we were childhood buds
yeah hey remember that I'm like no you
didn't show that a movie one jackasses
like weapon so we were childhood buds
and I will give this and this is where I
think Marc Webb deserves some credit
because I think this is a script thing
because if I were handed this script but
seriously you just want to introduce
this character now and I do I all right
I'll find the best way to film it I
think he found the best way to try to
re-establish a connection no I thought
so I think what
direction was solid but the script just
doesn't do it any favors because when
you introduce the character that quickly
you've got Harry popping up out of
nowhere so we're only just sort of given
this connection like hey we're childhood
buds but you're not really you haven't
seen each other in 10 years and no
amount of mark webs trickery is going to
be able to convince me otherwise that
there's such this deep connection and
there's certainly no villainous
connection he wants Spiderman's blood
that's a later plot development that
gets kicked into its own yeah yeah well
we lost the light we we do not have
mouth Spiderman's blood apparently yeah
so up Thanks you must see my face so all
of this so all of these things get
introduced in the last second so when
Harry pops up out of nowhere after
Electro's been killed in this climax
that goes on forever and it's
foreshadowed a bit as best Marc Webb can
but I mean the script still just he's
like I'm gonna destroy the thing you
love cuz because uh you know it's just
so late in the game that I'm just like
there's just no connection here there's
there's no rivalry that's been going on
for years there's even the amount of
hate he must and for spider-man I have
almost a hard time believing it because
it is so rush to the Raimi films credit
it starts off with Peter and Harry as
buds the connection Norman and Peter
have established very quickly because of
its disappointment the other side him
wanting to hastily make a connection
time goes by as you know it's like
you're hanging in that brain is MIA if
Harry and the Raimi films had done this
in spider-man 3 I think it could have
worked because you have that connection
um but and that brings up another point
which is the connection between Harry
and his father one of the seminal things
in the comic book which is sorely
missing here is Harry knew his father
and when his father dies his father
aunts him I mean literally in the comics
you see his ghost and this is a major
thing that continued on through tons of
like sagas and
shoes of Harry trying to overcome that
we get none of that you finally see
Norman Osborn if he's gonna game bad
because like well son here's some
medical secrets by but on top of that
again it's just sort of a disadvantage
because you feel like well yeah kid cuz
rainy films guy that did it and it's how
much you take how much do not do but it
you use any resent of India cut
something yeah something from this movie
need to set up Harry better like I'm not
against Harry doing it I'm just against
the fact that they they literally showed
us Norman and Harry both in the same
movie introduced both characters because
I'm sorry Norman was like he's
referenced in spider-man 1 that's it
yeah um you know so I'm more upset at
the fact that they just introduced these
characters and then just somehow managed
to rush through all of this to kill Gwen
Stacy at the end and the funny thing is
the feeling I have for Gwen Stacy's
death is because I thought they did a
great job at setting up their romance
I bought yes it was insight and as I was
going on I did not want to see her go I
said oh my god I know she was gonna die
and I don't want to see her done the
second the second Harry's talking about
their Peters like oh yeah you know she's
the one I love her something and Harry's
like oh it's good to know I'm like bingo
I'm like she's gonna be dead by the end
of this oh no I have a thought at the
graduation speech yeah and a future and
the lives ahead of all of us are just
like bye-bye yeah so it doesn't no man
we're pissing off the rainy gods are so
much so yeah it's the way they killed
her off in such a we just need to
shoehorn shoehorn it into this movie
somehow we just shove this in here at
the very end really I thought was a
total distance like an insult to a
character that done such a good job of
building up you know and I think your
wife right I bet she said you know
they're gonna make you know they're
gonna make another movie anyway why not
wait till the next movie because we have
them all the
4/6 yeah we mayor's made I'm sure the
sinister six and this yeah well why you
know or if you're gonna do it
x1 of the villains just make it about
the Green Goblin but that won't sell
okay save the Mary Jane thing for the
next one that you know just don't you
know sacrifice a touch of the marketing
for a really really good story this was
Sony's problem with three like it's so
hilarious to watch them make the same
damn mistakes again like it's all on
what we ought to give the families what
they want well you know we just want a
good story told from beginning then I
don't need a thousand villains you know
we don't need all of this stuff too much
stuff and it's like almost like
Halloween night it's like some of you
just shoving candy down your throat it's
like you know do you want like somebody
to come up to you like hey you know
here's some candy are awesome or d10
right like that's what Saudis doing this
burger that's not like cheerfully do to
myself Barbara I just saw it's just too
much but well and something that yeah
the funeral seen it well okay the the
funeral is just like you know first of
all I'm sick of funeral seeds and
spider-man films if I had to see him
standing over a grave going I'm just
fucking done but to this film's credit
I do remember this one because they very
effectively do this passage of time
where just a knee at the grave and then
you see you know cut away in the UCM and
leaves a different outfit they cut away
and they seem it's in the film sort of
fricking ended somewhere on there and
then instead
is everywhere it's like you know well I
think spider-man should come back he's
disappeared okay whatever maybe he'll
come back
well hey we have to give the Rio going
this don't mess anything comes ours some
little pawns like yeah a guy robot I
pulled your body and it's just like you
know and then the Spider Man comes in
just like while we sit five months pass
so that should emotionally cover
everything and it's just like well I'm
gonna keep making the jokes again doing
Michael a Spider Man things that's just
like if I if I'm wrong in this know if
I'm writing this is the same script
writing team ended into darkness if
that's the shame on you you did it it
into darkness it's fucking did it again
are you incapable of fucking having a
sad ending no no too sad we can have
actual drama we have to end with
everything's happy goofy nothing to see
here like that's exactly what into
darkness did it's Sarah everything it
was trying to do is like oh well high
five spot glad we solved that problem
this money seems very it seems like a
movie that's trying very hard to be good
and well directed and well perform but
is being eaten alive by notes that seems
like to me totally in the Wi-Fi studio
notes scriptwriter notes is like this or
know so many notes fine answers
everything we want this will be the cell
put this in here put that in there
that's a downer make this happy do this
to us well we want a little bit drama
not too much drama
do this uh and it's a shame because I
got the gwen stacy that really I wanted
like I she's in some ways better than
the comics I do think she's actually
smarter like it's been a while since
I've read them but like she's like super
genius in this one where she was just
really smart in the commets and you know
I got a good romance that you know was
kind of missing in the first one where
it was like Mary Jane and Peter with the
on-again off-again I don't know what the
fuck's going on and I finally got my
death scene with gwen stacy but it's
just like yeah that's botched so it it's
weird to get what you wanted but not
still right it's like yeah somewhere
it's like yeah we'll let 30-40 years
pass one though everybody will forget
about those movies though totally reboot
them again and something I'll just be
like hey let's go
really retro just combine all the
spider-man's together somehow make this
cool mishmash it maybe then we'll get
like our perfect spider-man movie that
just tells all the really good stuff
from the comics but also keeps it a film
and the progression from geeky Peter
into cool Peter and you know the villain
we can put our own spider-man film or we
use the Raimi films as the flashback
dude Tobey Maguire and Garfield look
enough alike no no no that's not even a
look but but it's I think the other
trend thing oh the sinister six thing I
will say that is where I kind of lost it
a bit because they they've got the the
man in the shadows with the the hat
walking and he walks by all of these
costumes which it's the sinister six
you've got the vulture you've got the
Rhino you've got dark eyes which is
confusing because I thought Doc Ock
formed the sinister six if I remember
the comics right but anyway but I'm kind
of sitting there I'm like you know in
the comics it was a bunch of super
villains that just kind of banded
together in this one I'm just kind of
laughing a bit because it's all an
Oscorp thing and I'm like oh designs
vulture wait that's a giant fucking ride
up like the flying suit I can kind of
see the octopus he has almost but I'm
like no really who's like you know
what's really gonna change the world
flying vulture wings hey Amanda the
vulture wings I said to just in case
people don't get that that's an electric
fucking guy little lightning bolt on the
side to that so still can't get over
there it's like of all the problems
releases that changing things like that
from the comics of the rib like yeah I'm
having a hard time swallowing this but I
know with any other spoilers if I mean
there's stuff like with Peters parents
and stuff but it's just like it's secret
government mumbo jumbo
I see I'm sorry all things that should
have been in the first movie like that's
what bothered me like okay you could
have had a shorter more coherent film if
you reveal that stuff in the first thing
like you should have want I remember
what was revealed about
I'm trying to remember it's like he got
the spider-man blood with his blood
making he was making my like this
fighter venom and found out it was gonna
be used for biological weapons at Norman
Osborn was selling it to so what well
exactly
Percival you know what fuck the only
thing I thought was actually effective
with them on the plane you know but
without their shake you can kind of
reminded me actually the first Abrams
Star Trek where you know you've got like
the ship crashing and he's like staring
at his wife and it's like weird and kind
of dreamlike and the thigh should go it
was really cool yeah I like one that
yeah was going down yet like you say I
like the silhouette against the window
yeah I thought that was pretty effective
um but yeah just so much stuff and then
just more setup for another film and I
feel I guess that's why if I'm with the
whole bunch they sitting I feel like
it's just a plot point hmm and I the
Senate using yeah it should be the
center pin and so should airy green
Eddie Green Goblin should be like the
center it needs to be only the Han Solo
in carbonite or the Luke I am your
father of the movie and instead it's
just oh we're going to Dagobah or
something or we got ourselves a
millennium formula is just like a plot
point one of many and I just it
shouldn't be that it should be the focal
point of the film and said it's one of
like why don't cry we're going to take
up oh my god no oh of course he cried
using here we gonna lose his x-wing
until Yoda is just like how they go
again
just on the basis of whiny prison every
week Isis is it so I present all oh okay
and speaking of things like unresolved
from the first film and how this which
one is it what's the one thing we still
haven't resolved uh travitt or the
lizard guy one or did he die oh go Ben
oh yeah where's the whole search for
Uncle Ben's killers still yeah little
man yeah okay guys
you know screw that shit I'm gonna fight
all my parents at LM I'm gonna think I'm
gonna find Uncle Ben's killer and my
helping who films you they had so many
platforms going out they forgot the ones
they set up in the last one you're
bringing up like that's how I totally
remember stupid script is Wow
I just yeah totally forgot about it
amazing I thought about that on the
drive back I'm like hey wait a sec
that's the big thing I was in that now
they're there like in that
well this Thank You Uncle Ben yeah cuz
spider-man so I don't even remember
Uncle Ben Tenn movie now which is a
problem and III remember uh Martin Sheen
as you do remember
I don't worry what was his famous line
uh with great not responsibility comes
great dot power something like that well
it was a great line I will say this
there is a great line where Sally Field
there I am mazes I'll be effective like
well it's just like your Uncle Ben used
to say that was like something something
responsibilities something great power
so yeah there it is this this is
probably the most confusing I mean I've
never been so torn on a movie it's much
like the first one but like so many
things I love and so many things like
what the yeah so I I still liked how
glad I saw it but yet I liked it while I
was also being simultaneously insulted
at the same time as a spider-man fan I
don't get I am a maybe that's Marc
Webb's contribution because it certainly
didn't come from the damn script I can
tell you so to to quote the movie it's
complicated it it is I'm spider-man